so I'm it's funny more of a hurry right
now so I apologize for the slightly more
bedbugs diagram them before but
anything's familiar enough right now
I've still got it set up just as I did
before in that here's the police car
this is the car which is thinking off
pass the interception here's the right
angle at the junction okay and I've got
60 T there because the cars going weight
increasing and I'm 200 minus a DT
because it starts at 200 and it heads
towards it at a speed of 80 feet a
second which by the way it's rather
ridiculous a feet a second that's P is
that anyway it's fast so now what do I
do
I always interested if you remember in
the rate of change of this angle okay so
trying to find the theta on DT okay so
we started by saying what's the
relationship between this theta and the
T's that I've got right and we said well
the ratio that I'm interested is tan
right and you've got opposite over
adjacent when T so you take that out and
here's where you're at okay now before
because we wanted to differentiate this
and we didn't know what this was
okay we would force just like in our
circle example we're forced to change
the subject to theta that introduced
inverse tree which let us down the
garden path of having to remember our
inverse trees derivatives okay but at
this point here can you see Thea and T
this is a function that is implicitly
defined okay there is the relationship
there it's just I haven't made it
obvious by taking tan inverse of both
sides okay but I can differentiate this
using implicit differentiation okay how
do I do it the variable I'm interested
in differentiating with respect to is T
okay so I'll differentiate both sides
with respect to T he's worse
okay now let's say let's this stop with
the pot that we do know how to do so
this right hand side
it's just question rule if you remember
and what did it end up remember it was
like - is anyone got it there when
they're working from when we disappear -
do you lots of different scratch because
you've got 10 times 10 minus 14 is where
is that okay
yep all right now when you have a look
at the left hand side okay this looks
weird because there no T's this at how I
differentiate well remember the key when
we were looking at that that circle then
we had x and y is to treat Y in this
case theta naught as just a produ rule
or a variable but to treat theta as a
function okay so what I think about here
okay I'll bring in chain rule okay so
let's differentiate the inside
okay what's the inside function the
inside function is Theta okay so the
derivative of the inside function is d
theta/dt i'm just differentiating theta
that function whatever it is with
respect to t okay that was the inside
now I do the outside which is 10 what's
the derivative of tan its SEC squared
right
101 card so I've got SEC square feet up
okay
all right now I suppose now I can kick
over this over the other side so I can
get defeat on the T on its own that
should be equal to 30
I guess cos squared yes I've just okay
so now I think about this say look I
want to know I think the question said
when T is equal to 2 right is that what
I was interested in when T is equal to 2
after Tuesday
okay so I can submit it to here and I'll
get some values but then I need to know
our theater is okay so again like before
we've got the derivative in terms of two
different variables so that's what
implicit differentiation gives this as a
result which is a little unusual but
it's not harder to work with because if
I know what T is then I could know what
all of these are and I can work out
where theater is right or rather I can
work out cuz theories so when T is 2
this will be 200 minus 160 which is 40
yes when T is 2 this will be 120 okay if
I want to work out cos theta I need to
know the hypotenuse as well
so 40 squared 120 v conservative media
varnish what's that one use it is square
root of the hypotenuse squared is 4 T
squared which is sixteen hundred plus 14
which is what's that 160 now sorry
hundred sixteen thousand yeah try that's
H squared so H is equal to what it's not
it's not because I need another zero
donor okay but I'm gonna simplify this a
little bit anyway because I want cos
theta which is adjacent over hypotenuse
adjacent over hypotenuse
yeah so I'm gonna say I can take out
what's a square number I can take out of
here I can take 400 out right so if I
take 400 out of here it'll become a 20
at the front right and this will be if I
divide by 400 it'll be 40 right yeah 100
let's pick a bigger number than that
okay still over 1600 so I end over the
40 that's better
10 yeah yeah that's better
that's that's all I get okay so that's
the hypotenuse therefore cos theta will
be adjacent on hypotenuse which is 40 on
40 root n yeah so one on root n so
therefore cos squared theta will be one
on ten that okay all right so I've got
my cos square theta I've got my tea okay
so now I can chuck them into my
derivative which is 30 times whatever
tips that's 3 over 10 minus 8 squared
which is 3 on 2 squared which is 4 which
is the same measurement that we got
before which is rather a relief isn't it
ok so which method do you use it's
always a bit risky for me to teach you
more methods because that can be more
confusing like you get to a question and
then you have to pick a mess
right but it can also have a payoff
right what's the benefit here you still
have to do chain rule sorry you still
did your question rule so you kind of
avoid that you still have a chain rule
of sorts here probably the only thing we
dodged is differentiating 10 inverse
yeah because that's what we do had here
when we change the subject when your
answer pops out